when I heard Apple was making a Godzilla
TV show I was
like I don't know why I put that in
there I just thought it was hilarious
Monarch Legacy of monsters is another
entry into the Warner Brothers monster
verse which features films such as
2014's Godzilla Kong Skull Island and
Kong versus Godzilla I wasn't expecting
Too Much from the first two episodes but
I got to say it's been kind of fun so I
thought I'd put together this video of
the biggest theories and questions out
there I've also left timestamps below so
you can see all the topics I'll be
covering but before we begin make sure
to like And subscribe I'm planning on
covering the entire season Bridging the
Gap between our flashbacks in the 1950s
and 1973 is Bill Randa whether you
believe these two are 21 years apart
well I'll leave that up to you if you've
seen Skull Island you'll know that it
was Bill Randa Who convinced US senator
Al Willis to fund an expedition there
this was an attempt to prove his hollow
Earth theory that that a sort of world
within a world exists home to the Titans
we saw this world in Godzilla versus
Kong Bill Randa will meet his demise on
Skull Island but not before throwing
this mysterious bag into the ocean we'll
see the side emblazened with his name
William Randa and the Monarch logo it's
implied that the bag remained at sea for
40 years until was picked up by a
Japanese fishing tler in 2013 how it got
from the tler to Hiroshi randa's hidden
safe is a mystery yet to be solved but I
have a sneaking suspicion Kate's dad who
has the answer to this question isn't
dead in fact it was his death that
brought Kate to Japan she's here to
settle some of his Affairs after it was
revealed his plane went down in Alaska
and the wreckage never found it's in
Japan where she discovers her father
lived a double life complete with a
different wife and son but more on that
later bill worked for Monarch an
organization founded in 1946 to study
MOS or massive unidentify ified
terrestrial organisms it's this group
that Kate sees taking pictures of
Godzilla on gday an event depicted in
2014's Godzilla with Tim a monarch
employee hellbent on retrieving these
files it seems the mystery behind
Monarch and what it wants will be one of
the series biggest questions inside the
bag are a half dozen data storage tapes
it's old technology but with the help of
Cano's friend May they're able to
decipher these encrypted tapes we'll see
us slew of classified and redacted
Monarch memos but upon opening them it's
triggered a monarch recognition code
informing Monarch that it's been opened
we'll meet this woman named Collins who
works in data culling she's the one who
informs Tim of the breach but what I
found more interesting was this giant
wall where she works it almost looks
like a subway map but obviously these
guys aren't working for public transit I
wonder if these are the movements of
different mudos or perhaps underground
Networks mudo used to travel on one of
the tapes they'll find this map which
has similar lines like those found on
the wall it looks like that big
satellite map in his office according to
canaro he and Kate's father Hiroshi made
software for satellites maybe Monarch
used hiroshi's satellite software to
track these mudos after all Kate said
that the Monarch soldiers on gday acted
as if they were expecting Godzilla's
arrival Collins here asked him if he
wants to quote kick this up to Verdugo
who we can assume is his boss but for
some reason he wants to keep this
potentially catastrophic leak from her
it could mean that Tim might have
ulterior motives when it comes to
grabbing these files the first of two
major flashbacks is set in 1952
Philippines Lee Shaw has been tasked
with escorting Dr Kira as she
investigates strange readings of
Airborne radio isotopes now these
Isotopes aren't from nuclear bombs but
originate from the island itself while
trashing his father's office canaro
finds a film canister marked Philippines
52 knowing that bill Randa had a film
camera during that time it's likely
footage of their time there we also
learned that koo's radiation chart and
Bill's map of locals identifying a
mysterious Dragon match up this
radiation might be what Lee saw this is
most likely the result of the
dragon-like muto they meet who's made
its home in the USS Len the same ship
Bill Randa was stationed on in 1943 when
he was a part of the US Navy its first
in Kong Skull Island that we learned
bill was the only Survivor of this mudo
attack on the lon you heard of the USS
Len neither did the public an attack
which the US military claimed was the
result of a Japanese sub it's what
spurred Bill's research wanting to prove
to humanity that these monsters exist
we'll see this picture of the destroyed
Lon in Skull Island but it's never
mentioned how it made its way to the
jungles of the Philippines perhaps in
this show they're claiming this ship was
taken by by the muto and dropped here as
a feeding ground or maob reproductive
ritual we'll see men who've died over 9
years ago with their bodies seemingly
preserved the second major flashback
happens in Kazakhstan 1959 this is 7
years after Koo Lea and Bill had their
encounter with a Muto on the USS Latin
since then KO and Bill have developed a
romantic relationship they're most
likely married as we see both characters
wear wedding rings they've come to
continue their research attempting to
prove that a vast underground network of
tunnels connect under the Earth's
surface a local kid has a frightening
tale that the communist government
burned a hole deep into the Earth's
crust which may have opened a way for
the mudos to come up top now this place
is supposed to be off limits due to
radiation we'll see this Chernobyl like
nuclear plant but when KO checks her
Guyer counter for radiation every time
there's a spike it fades away as if
being absorbed these insectoid type eggs
feed off the radiation and as luck would
have it as soon as they arrive to gather
a sample they break from their shells
and attack this is where KO dies but
since she falls into this crevice we
can't say with 100% certainty she's
truly gone according to canaro hoshi's
mother who is K died when he was young
so it's possible that he was just a baby
or child when his parents were in
Kazakhstan in episode 2 Lee Smith says
that Hiroshi Randa didn't just disappear
without a trace this goes against what
the Alaskan police said who claimed his
bush plane went down during a storm but
oddly enough no wreckage was ever found
when Tim finds out that canaro is the
son of Hoshi he knows it's not a good
sign so whatever Hiroshi was planning
seems to be counter to Monarch canaro
even claims that whatever his father was
up to might explain why he had two
families he had some reason for doing
what he did I thought it was pretty
great to have Kurt Russell and his son
Wyatt play both the young and old
versions of Lee Smith a lot must have
certainly happened between 1959 the last
time we see young Le and 2015 the first
time we see old Le when the gang find
him at an old folks home run by Monarch
which is secretly a pseudo prison to
keep tabs on him he's more than ready to
join them on a mission to find their
father and I actually found this to be a
bit of a red flag like this guy has
probably been here for years and
immediately cuts off his ankle monitor
and is like you son of a I'm in
what I'm trying to say is that I'm
keeping an eye on him in case he's
secretly working for Monarch in an
attempt to get them to lead them to
hirosi who seems to hold the keys on the
Mysteries that are going on here an
interesting worldbuilding scene I
enjoyed was the plane being
decontaminated since mudos are attracted
to radiation this may be the
government's way of preventing another
attack but as the passenger beside Kate
says it merely creates the illusion of
safety now it's time to get into the
trailer sleuthing section where we go
over the season's trailers for Clues on
where the show is headed keep in mind I
won't be covering every shot just the
ones that pertain to the story ahead
here we see some old film footage and
Lee watching it as we'll see throughout
the trailers I get the feeling Lee and
KO might have hooked up this discovery
may have been what caused her roshi to
become estrange from Lee who became like
this Uncle SL surate father to him after
his father's death this quick shot of ko
and Lee dancing leads me to believe this
even more so more film footage which
appears to show Military Officers and
some Godzilla spikes Hiroshi is alive
unless this is some sort of flashback
check out the weird looking ball device
in the background it looks a bit similar
to the device Shaw and a group of others
get into here with the Monarch logo I
totally get astronaut Vibes here but
instead of space my guess is they're
making their way to the hollow ground
the home of the Titans we saw in
Godzilla versus Kong in the behind thes
scenes trailer we see yet another one of
these balls sometime in the 1950s Lee
says in voiceover that he wanted Monarch
to be an organization that protected
both humanity and the Titans so him
being on the outs with them would
suggest Monarch may have deviated from
that original plan we'll see two big
locations featured in these trailers one
a desert and another someplace super
cold Alaska was mentioned as being the
place hiroshi's plane went down so maybe
that's where this is both the desert and
Arctic locations are home to Titans this
new new one and Godzilla we'll see
canaro tape this piece of paper with
holes in it which reflect spots of light
on what looks to be his father's map or
something similar to it whether this is
a constellation or something else
entirely is yet to be known they point
to specific coordinates and if you look
up the one here it corresponds to Kanda
Algeria somewhere up north we see these
Aurora Borealis type lights emanating
from below it kind of reminds me of the
same lights Lee saw in the Philippines
back in 52 we'll see his re reaction to
it as well the gang ends up making their
way to Monarch headquarters so it'll be
interesting to see how these two forces
come together that's about it for
episodes 1 and two of Monarch now I turn
it over to you what are your thoughts
and theories for the upcoming season I
want to hear them in the comments below
thanks for watching please be sure to
like And subscribe and for more Matt
takes you can follow me on Twitter and
Instagram at thinkstory YT until next
time
remember Let Them
Fight